People want to follow their passion, but
don't even know what it actually means.
So, the root of the word passio is Latin
for suffering. So, it's not about doing
what you love, it's about finding
something that you love enough that it's
worth suffering for. And so, pick
something worth suffering for.
And what's interesting about this is
that the first usage of the word passion
came from passion of Christ, which was
literally Jesus Christ's crucifixion
story. And so, it's interesting that
this has been bastardized into following
your passion means doing what you love.
And the reason I'm making this video is
because
I had a young man stop me, say that he
quit his job, went all in on
entrepreneurship, but then he didn't
like what his life looked like.
Um and so, he asked me what he should
do. And the reality was that he quit
because he thought that he was doing
something wrong because he wasn't loving
every second of it. So, here's the big
problem. Your passion only exists in the
vague, not in the specific. So, even if
you start a business around what you
believe to be your passion, 95% of what
you do every day, if you're successful,
will not be your passion. You'll just
have very brief moments where you'll do
that specific thing, if at all, and then
assuming that that thing never changes,
which it will. And so, this kind of like
passion window is very short-lived, or
it's only possible as an employee where
you actually stick to doing the same
thing every single day within kind of a
larger machine, or solopreneur that
chooses not to scale. Not a business
owner unless you choose to love business
ownership as the thing you're quote
passionate about, which means that
you're willing to suffer for it, right?
And
the ultimate version of this comes at
the very end. If you keep doing the
thing that you are, you know, that you
suffer for for a long period of time,
eventually you can get to true ownership
where something, you know, operates on
its own, and then you have all your time
back, right? And so, let me give you an
example. So, I run, every month I meet
with 10 entrepreneurs. It's the most
expensive quote service that we sell. Um
it's obviously unscalable, but I we meet
with bigger businesses. So, usually the
average business size around 10-ish
million.
Um and we meet in a group of 10. And I
meet with them, and it's something that
I absolutely love doing. I look forward
to the days uh whenever they're coming
up, but I would absolutely hate it if I
had to do it every day. And so, how can
that be true, right? How can I love
something, but if I did a lot of it, I
would hate it? Well, it's like, well, I
love There's a certain pizza place that
I love going to once or twice a year,
and it's amazing. If I was forced to eat
it every single meal, I wouldn't like it
as much. And so, we have this
misconception about following your
passion. And in both scenarios, if you
do the same thing all the time that you
quote love, you'll stop loving it
because you'll get so much of it. The
fact that it's rare is what makes you
love it. And if it stays rare, then it
means that the vast majority of your
time you're not really doing it. And so,
it's just a complete myth, and I
understand why people tell younger
people or other newer entrepreneurs
like, "Oh, follow your passion." It's
just because it's politically correct,
and it's easy to say, but it's not the
truth. Right? And so, you're not going
to have the perfect amount of sunshine
for the perfect amount of time, right?
And so, let me reframe how I think
through this is that you want moments.
You want good days. Not a never-ending
work state of this jolly thing that you
love because eventually you'd adapt, and
you would get bored, just like
everything else. And so, here's the
underline.
You're using the excuse of a lack of
passion to disguise your inability to
handle difficulty, to handle being able
to repeatedly do things that you don't
enjoy to have something that you do find
meaningful have happen. Real quick, I'm
going to show you the exact 10-stage
roadmap from zero to 100 million plus
that less than 1% of companies finish
I've now done multiple times. And so, I
can say with a lot of confidence that
these are the stages as headcount
increases that you need to get through,
and I broke each of these down by eight
different functions of the business,
what the constraint feels like, like
what are the symptoms of it when you're
going through it, and then what steps we
actually took to graduate. And we've
done this across software, physical
products, uh service businesses, brick
and mortar, all of this, and it works.
And it's my gift to you. It's absolutely
free. And so, the link's in the
description, but you just go
acquisition.com/roadmap,
enter your info, and it'll spit it right
back to you, all free. And so, this is
what actually happens in the real world,
right? So,
unless you get very good at your
passion, you will have to do things that
you like le- you like less to pay your
bills. Period. Like that's that's real,
right? And then number two, as soon as
you are good at your passion, your
demand will outstrip your supply of
time, and 95% of what you do will will
not be the thing you love, but stuff
that you do to support the thing you
love, which you may indeed not love. And
so, the 5% of your passion that's left
over will only be there if your passion
doesn't change, which it also will,
which means the vast majority of your
life you will not be doing things that
you are passionate about. And in the
tiny instance you do, it's likely
short-lived.
And so, let me let me frame why I think
this is so important. If you were
playing a video game, and day one I
said, "Enter this cheat code, you have
max life, max strength, max money, max
good looks."
And then you go through the the whole
game, and it's incredibly easy, what
would you do? You just never play the
game. You wouldn't even it wouldn't even
be fun, right? And so, we on some level
know that we have to suffer. It's not
about winning the lottery, right? It's
not about the outcome. We can't say,
"Oh, I'm really ambitious. I won the
lottery." That's the the ambition and
the passion go hand in hand in that you
were stating to the world, and more
importantly to yourself, that you are
willing to suffer for this thing because
you have deemed it important enough to
suffer for, which is why the striving,
the suffering is quite essentially
human, and not something to be avoided.
Growing a business is really painful and
sucks.
Being in a plateaued business is really
painful and sucks. Being in a decaying
business
is really painful and it sucks.
Entrepreneurship is hard.
Being an employee is hard. Being broke
is hard. Being rich is hard. Married
people
want to be single. Single people want to
be married. I'm not saying all the time,
but I'm saying there is suffering in
every path of life.
And so, I see the the the core issue,
especially with entrepreneurs,
especially new coming entrepreneurs, is
that they look at their existing state
and think,
"I am suffering, and therefore there's
something wrong with this.
I need to change this because if I
change this, I will no longer suffer."
But change will also cause suffering.
And so, it's the fact that you claim
there's a problem with suffering that's
creating even more suffering and also
sacrificing the thing that you said you
would suffer for because you're not
going to achieve it because you never
walked down the path. And so, one of my
favorite sayings around this
it's of myself, it's my own saying, so
it's a bit self-aggrandizing. But
success and failure are on the same
path, failure is just an earlier exit.
That's it. To that younger entrepreneur
who I was talking to,
no matter what path you choose,
it will be hard. And so, pick one that
pays better if that's what you think is
worth it. And so, suffering is a fixed
cost, right? The suffering on all paths
is a fixed cost. And so, the secret to
getting what you want is doing lots of
things that you don't want. And so, no
matter what you do, it will suck. And
so, pick the things that pay better. The
goal is to reframe reality so that bad
things are good, not to try and only
experience good things. I'm going to say
that again. The goal is to reframe your
living experience so that bad things are
good, not to try and only experience
good things. It would be like looking
outside and saying every day that it
rains, I will be upset, rather than
there are benefits to rain, and there
are benefits to sunshine. And so, you
have to change your frame, not your
conditions, your perceptions, not
reality. And so, let me give you a
hypothetical. What if I told you you had
two options, and both rides cost 10
bucks, right? And one ride is one that
you want, and the other one is one that
you hate. Which one would you pick? They
both cost 10 bucks. The thing you hate
and the thing you love.
Well, you'd pick the thing that you
love. Now, let me say let me give you
another option, a third option. Let me
give you the option that's the thing
that you love unbelievably, like huge
love. It's so it's so unbelievable that
you're not even sure you want to try to
ride the ride because you're not even
sure if it's going to finish the way you
want. But it still costs 10 bucks. Which
one would you do now? You probably pick
the one that you really really love,
right? So, then what if I told you that
you're going to suffer the same amount
in all three paths that you pick in
life? The thing that you hate,
the thing that you think is a moderate
or reasonable goal, or the thing that
you really want to swing for the fences
for.
All three have the same amount of
suffering.
Like think about it.
You will suffer the same. You'll suffer
regret more here, you'll suffer
difficulty more here,
but you'll suffer the same. It's a fixed
cost.
And so, this is why
this is why aiming big is so is so real
for me. Is that like, what's the
alternative?
Aiming small and also still suffering?
Like the the fears that we have on the
downside are not true. They're just
suffering.
And so, I say all this to say,
delaying your pursuit because you're
waiting to find your passion is a fool's
errand.
Find something that people value.
Do that thing even though it sucks.
Realize there is no greener grass on the
other side. It all sucks on both sides.
One of my favorite my favorite one of my
favorite CEOs that I've ever had,
Suzanne, used to say, "It's greener on
the other side of the fence cuz it's
fertilized with shit."
And so, there's on both sides of
the fence. You just haven't gotten over
and stepped in it yet. And one of my
favorite Chinese proverbs is,
"Everything must be hard before it can
be easy."
And so, my two cents is, do not try to
be passionate about what you do,
but try to be passionate about why and
how you do it.
The reason for that is because your why
and your how will persist. They are
internal. Your what, the thing you like
doing,
you like carving little miniature ships,
you like playing video games, you like
painting, whatever it is, it's external,
and you have little control over that.
Those are treats.
Those are moments.
They can't be requirements. And so, this
is from a personal level me having gone
through a little bit of this myself,
like questioning the reason for working
when you no longer need any money,
right? That's
you know, whatever your opinion about
me,
like that is very true.
I do not need to work. What I had to
realize for myself was I am not the
goal. I am the goal in terms of who I
want to become, but the self-servingness
cannot be the goal.
Because you will satisfy your own needs
relatively quickly, especially if you
get good at anything.
Everyone's bar is different, but you
will satisfy it. Doesn't matter who you
are.
And so, that why has to be bigger than
you,
or you'll only be able to come overcome
obstacles that are smaller than you.
And this is why I believe it has to be
eternal.
And so, Victor Frankl famously said, "If
a man has a big enough why, he can
overcome almost any how."
And Rogan had this quote that I love
about this, which is a man will crawl
through broken glass with a smile.
You need a goal worth suffering for.
The goal is your passion, not the path.
If you love the goal enough, the path
stops mattering.
Right? So, let me give an example to
make this concrete. So,
imagine your future family and your
future wife, right?
People who go to war fight for different
reasons. Freedom, duty, protecting their
loved ones, not letting their friends
down.
None of this is their love, but they
love them enough that they'll do
anything including die for them.
And my definition of love from an
operationalizing perspective is that you
measure it by what you're willing to
give up in order to maintain it. The man
who loves the journey will walk further
than the man who loves the destination.
But the man who walks to protect his
family will walk until the other man
dies.
So, let me tell you something cool about
this. So, they've done research on this
where they have someone get shocked, and
then eventually they tap out, right? At
a pain threshold. When they told the
same people that their loved ones were
in the other room and every shock they
took, their loved ones wouldn't have to,
their threshold tripled. Think about how
crazy this is. And the reason I think
this is so relevant is that like if you
want to do big things, it will cost you
great pain.
And so, your
the why is your passion, not the path.
And so, this is why people talk about
finding your passion because it'll get
you through the inevitable hard times
that come. But whenever you hear someone
say that, first off, I don't think they
have bad intent. I think they just don't
think about it as much. Um, but when you
hear that, just remember it will get you
through the inevitable hard times that
come is the definition of passion. It is
the requisite for it being your passion.
If passion, the literal translation in
Latin is suffering and endurance, to
endure suffering. The Passion of Christ,
the crucifixion story, the first usage
of suffering in this context, then don't
you think that like the thing that
you're going for, maybe it's to set
yourself up financially, to set your
family up financially, to move into a
better neighborhood, to set your kids up
to have something that you didn't have?
Like don't you think that's worth
suffering for? Whatever that is for you.
And so like I I
I want to make duty cool again.
I want to make it cool for like a man to
go in a field and work a rice paddy and
know that they did a job
because of who they did it for.
And so for me,
my passion, what I'm willing to suffer
for, is helping men provide.
It's something that I feel deeply about.
And that's to be fair, it's not like I
don't want women to provide, I want them
to provide too, but I'm saying like what
is what is the closest to my core?
Obviously business tactics works no
matter who's using them, right? But I
see the core components of me
and men specifically as provide,
protect, procreate.
And I can't help do all of them to be
clear,
>> [laughter]
>> right? Some of that's on you.
Um, but what I believe I can help with
is at least one of those three.
And there are many days where I do not
enjoy some of the downstream effects of
what I do.
But I do enjoy what happens as a result.
And I spend so much time on my books and
this content
because I think on my deathbed it will
matter more than any wealth that I
accumulate.
And the ironic part about my role is
that in order to influence more people,
I need to continue to gain access to
increase credibility. And so, our
outcomes are inextricably linked. I have
to succeed. I have to learn the next
step so that I can teach it. And that
carries me through the pain of
uncertainty and the failures of my many
misjudgments. And you can become
passionate about your work because you
become passionate about what your work
gets you. And I think for some reason
talk about it's the journey not the
destination, but like in some ways it's
about the destination so that you can
tolerate the journey. I don't think
Frodo on his on his on his, you know, in
his quest to to destroy the ring was
like, "Man, I'm not sure if I'm
passionate about this."
I think he absolutely was passionate
about it. He was willing to die for it.
He was willing to give up his home for
it, his friends for it, his family for
it. And so, I think we all on some level
strive to have that. Something that I've
been saying to to Layla a lot is that
like something I believe to my bones is
that a man must have a quest.
You have to drive towards something.
And so, the problem is that we believe
that when we see monsters and dragons on
the trail, society is telling us, "Oh,
this is not the right path for you
because
it's not all sunshine and rainbows and
unicorns." No, that path not only does
it not exist, even if it did exist,
you'd
And hedonistic adaptation is a real
thing. And to be clear, there are
elements of my work, of my path that I
love. I love writing.
But basically anything besides that, I
don't like 10 out of 10 enjoy. I love
writing. I enjoy lifting. Lifting I
would say is super high on my like
enjoyment list. I enjoy eating and
hanging out after I work out with people
I like. And those are basically my
emotional highs. But if I did it all the
time, which I know because I tried to do
it. I owned a gym. I started a gym
because I thought, "Oh, if I eat food
with people I like and work out all the
time, then my life's going to be happy."
And let me tell you, the most miserable
year of my life was the first year I
started the gym. The most miserable of
the last 15, the hardest year of my
life.
And so, the thing is is that you
habituate to the good, but you still
suffer through the bad.
You get used to it.
And so, definitionally, you need
something that you cannot achieve in
order to continue to strive, to continue
to fight, especially when you don't want
to. And so,
I'm not going to speak for, you know,
women and men, but especially for men, I
believe that we need to give ourselves
permission to earn, permission to
strive, permission to suffer,
and grow as a result of that suffering.
Because the stretch between who you are
and who is required, the person you have
to become to handle your current
struggle, is the pain of growth. And we
can't wish for the benefits of growth
without accepting the cost or the price
of growth,
which is the suffering.
And so, you could even say that growth
is your passion. But if growth is your
passion, that means that you're willing
to do many miserable things in order for
it to happen, which means you're willing
to suffer to achieve it, which means
that if you're suffering right now in
pursuit of the thing that you find
meaningful, there is nothing wrong with
you. You are not on the wrong path, and
this is how it works. And the people who
try to tell you otherwise either don't
know better or actively are trying to
destroy you. And I do this work because
I really do find it the most meaningful.
I put up with plenty of because I
like like it's hard for people to
comprehend this. I took out $42 million
in distributions before my 46 million
dollar exit.
At 31.
Put that in a bank account and put 5% a
year on it. I don't live that fancy.
It was an active choice
to take this on and do this because when
I took the year off, I was very
miserable. I had no quest. And I
remember being in Mexico.
Layla and I went there for a month or
two, I can't remember. Um, and I
remember every day I would look out at
this beautiful ocean, this massive
mansion that we had rented while we were
there, and I had to think to myself
like,
what what do I find meaningful?
What what moves me?
And when I say moves me, I mean calls me
to take action. What is a cause that I'm
willing to suffer for?
And for me, it's it's helping younger me
out. Because I know how much pain I was
in. But a portion of that pain was
because I had other people in my ear
telling me there was something wrong
with me for the pain I experienced. That
there was something wrong with the path.
And so, they would sow these seeds of
doubt and uncertainty into me, and then
that made the path so much more painful
because the whole time I was wondering,
like am I like I'm go I for sure know
I'm going through the suffering, but I
don't know if I'm doing it for the right
reason. And so, I think that if you
provide for your family,
like you've won.
And most people, like if we're really
being real, think back to the last major
life change that you had. Once it
stabilized, you're probably close to
about as happy as you are now. And I'll
I'll I'll make a like I'll make a
prediction. After your next major life
change, you'll have a short period of
improved subjective well-being, and then
you'll return to baseline. And so like
if we assume these things to be true,
and the our subjective well-being, how
we rate ourselves, how we feel
day-to-day is about the same pretty much
no matter what,
then that steady state becomes our
existence. And so, that's the $10.
That's the fixed cost of living. But we
can change the reward.
We can change what we do it for or for
whom we do it.
And I think that's
that's what got me riled up enough to
make this video. Like there's nothing
wrong with you if you were pursuing
something for the purpose of something
that you find meaningful independent of
how hard it is. To make this real for
some of you guys who are going through
it right now, when I was sleeping on my
gym floor, I say that in one sentence, I
was sleeping on my gym floor.
But what the sentence fails to compress
is that like that's a turf floor that I
used to get rashes on
um because it was like covered in sweat
and I didn't clean it that often. And
when I was sleeping there, I was barely
sleeping because it was underneath of a
parking garage and they had these metal
dividers and it was a concrete box and
so these cars would drive over it at all
hours of the night, usually like kids
around my age cuz I was 22
driving there who were college kids or
just out of college partying on the
roof. And so I could hear these cars
that were like
and it would like wake me up like and I
would, you know, do the billing until,
you know, sometimes 11:00 at night uh
and then I would have like this
adrenaline and this sweat sleep that I'd
go through cuz there was no AC in the
gym because it was in California. And my
first session would be five, people
would get there at 4:30 so I'd open the
gym at 4:15. And the thing is is you can
hear that and I remember like
I slept for less than I would sleep for
around four to five hours every night,
but I did that consistently for about
six months. And it got to the point like
I remember where I could I could
actually fall asleep leaning against
walls.
Um and I remember thinking to myself
during that period of my life like
anyone who ever had sleeping issues just
simply isn't working hard enough. I
don't think that's true. I for sure
think that if you were sleep deprived
enough like you will not have sleeping
issues. Um
but I bring this up to say that like I
was like I remember showering at the LA
Fitness didn't have flip flops and I
still have athlete's foot in one of my
feet because of what I caught at that
place that I still deal with. Um and I I
literally had all my stuff in my car cuz
I drove to California in my car and all
my stuff was there. And so
when I say one line of like I slept on
the floor
like, you know, I get it. I understand
it because like while I was going
through it like I had no promise that it
was going to work.
Right? And like I had also given up
something that was significant. I had a
white collar job and every person that I
knew, and this might not be real for
some of you, but every person that I
knew when I decided to quit and start my
own gym business
actually had higher status than me. So
because they all had white collar jobs
and I quit to start what most people
would consider a blue collar business.
And so
I lost all social status that I had
within like the girls that I knew and
the guys that I knew because I was no
longer like on the investment banking
management consulting path.
Um and like I went to this prestigious
college so that I could open up that
world and then instead left everything
so that I could become a personal
trainer which requires zero
uh credibility at all.
And so like if you are going through
your version of hard time. Now for you
maybe it is more sleepless nights, maybe
it is physical exhaustion, maybe it's
more the social stuff of feeling like
your peers are getting ahead of you and
wondering what's wrong with you and like
you're for sure sacrificing this time,
money and taking on this risk, but
you're not sure if it's going to work.
The only thing that I can say is that
every single person who was successful
shares that path with you.
And the only thing that I can tell you
that got me through that period of time
was that I committed to not stopping. I
never I didn't know when I would succeed
or if I would succeed, but I did know
that I wouldn't stop. And that if I
didn't stop that I couldn't be called a
failure. And so that was the big thing.
Like I realized that if I had if I had
if I had to stop, then I would have to
explain stopping. That still meant that
other people's opinions mattered to me
to be clear. But if I was like if I just
keep going, I can always be like I'm
still doing it. I'm still doing it. And
as long as I had enough to cover food,
which doesn't really cost that much
I was going to be okay.
And so a lot of times the worst case
scenarios I would encourage you to think
out in more specificity what really is
the worst case scenario. As someone who
slept in the car or slept on the floor
like you know what? Just like everything
else, it becomes
steady state. Right? Like I remember
when I was broker and had amazing
memories.
And I remember being richer and having
amazing memories. I remember having
terrible memories now having more money
and I remember having terrible memories
then having less money.
For sure money will give you options,
but it will not really dramatically
change your subjective well-being
because that is very internal. A lot of
us already know this, but we still want
to make sure and go get the money
anyways. But I see a man's work as
something that's incredibly
core to who we are. I I don't know if
it's the same for men. I can only speak
to my own experience, but I see my work
and what I choose to do with my hands
and my mind and my like every day. Like
my grandfather who was the person that I
was closest with my family,
um he came here. He was an immigrant. Um
one of nine born in Macedonia. He was
the smartest of them so they sent him to
boarding school cuz he was smarter than
his siblings.
Uh did well, then ran from the Nazis for
multiple years during the Holocaust. Um
and then from there came uh
to the US after being in Europe after
the World War
um and to start his his practice here
and then he had to retake all of the
exams because none of the European
uh standardizations mattered in the US.
So he had to retake everything again in
the US in language he didn't understand.
Um and so, you know, obviously he he he
became successful. He had my mother and
my mother had me. And but he would he
and I would sit there and talk and he
says you have two hands and one mind.
That's it.
And and I always thought about that. So
it's like we have two hands and one mind
and if we think that like no matter what
path you choose like poverty is tough,
right? And so is so is growth and so is
risk. Like everything sucks.
Right? I I tweeted this thing the other
day cuz I was texting someone it says
everything is hard and no one cares.
I like I I am able to make these videos
despite some of the personal cost that
it comes that comes with it. For sure
there's personal benefit, but there are
there are costs and there are benefits
because when I have those those moments
where you're like shoot, what if I like
go off this ramp and I'm about to die or
like you you have some health scare cuz
you see a lump somewhere and you're like
oh my god is it cancer and it's not or
whatever.
Those moments you like you do this quick
check on your life and you're like do I
need to change everything about what I'm
doing? And for me when I have those
moments I look back and I say like this
is what I would have done like
I feel like the work that I do
helps people and it's something that I
find interesting.
And so I do it. And much of my day does
not include that.
And much of my life leading up to this
did not include that. And I've said this
example before, but I will make it
again.
I thought that pursuing my passion meant
being in fitness and because I liked
working out. But me working out with
friends is such a very small slice of my
life. And when I actually started a gym
and took it all the way to the natural
extreme, I'm back at the beginning again
right now with a gym that I can work out
with the people that I like and I do not
have a gym business.
And so I say this to say that like
the suffering will not stop.
Like we work because on some level we
think the suffering will end and it just
won't. And so I think if you can accept
the suffering as the toll that you pay
on all these paths
then at least you get to pick where you
go. And I think that
is something worth fighting for.